welcome back to the David pakman show I
Am David packman if there were a cloning
experiment that went terribly terribly
wrong
let's talk a little bit more today about
Heather McDonald and the right wing
obsession with race and racism and not
the the way that they project on the
left about being oh you're upset
everything's about race everything's
about race in the way that they want to
make white Christian nationalism the
order of the day for the country
and a lot of people push back when I say
that when I say that the Republican
party is the largest white supremacy
organization on the planet
I stand behind it
yesterday Charlie Kirk had a woman named
Heather McDonald on his show and I want
to get you a little acquainted with this
regular Fox News guest Heather McDonald
a woman who is a tireless defender of
police no matter what they do no matter
what news comes out no matter what video
is made public
tireless defender of police these are
some headlines Media Matters put
together from her various just a few by
the way not not all of them just a a
smattering of headlines of quotes from
her appearances with Tucker Carlson the
host of fox news's evening white
supremacy fireside chat
teaching diversity curriculum in schools
will destroy any possibility of further
civilizational advance
we should not be bringing more black
children into this country if Democrats
think America is racist
police are forced to arrest black men at
higher rates quote by the facts of the
crime and finally good law abiding
blacks aren't calling for the
abolishment
of police
leave it to aging white lady to tell you
what good law-abiding blacks are doing
well she was on with Charlie Kirk the
Twitchy zeppelin-headed freak over at
turning points USA another verging on
very dangerous character
and they were having a conversation
about policing you know after the
release of the beating of Tyree Nichols
it is now on the lips of every
conservative in the country either
making excuses for or outright denying
that there was a problem with it
and Charlie Kirk makes an assertion that
is is and has been and will continue to
be a legitimate white supremacist
talking point
many of you know that my my wife my
co-host and my partner in content
creation Brittany page was raised in a
virulent white supremacist household
we talk all the time about this
normalization of white supremacy and
white nationalism in the country things
that she grew up with only whispered
about in private are now on the public
agenda they are now on the docket for
Republicans to get Advanced as policy in
the United States and because of that it
has normalized Clips like you're getting
ready to see of Charlie Kirk watch this
the for years I've been told by
activists that blacks commit they don't
commit more crimes but the reason they
might and the statistics is because
there's more police in their
neighborhood it's the exact opposite of
a way to view it there's more police in
your neighborhoods because blacks commit
more crimes period
it's like you know we always hear about
well riots are caused by the police
showing up in riot gear and that causes
everybody to Riot no it's it's as you
say it's the exact opposite causality
the reason the police are there in ride
gear is you guys are rioting if you
don't want the police in Rye gear how's
about you stay home and or or protest
peacefully and don't start throwing
Molotov cocktails at police precincts
um yep he says smugly
one Charlie just a little bit of advice
maybe get a bigger shirt collar I know
you only have like a 14 and a half inch
neck but that collar is doing a lot of
work
to stay buttoned
neither here nor there though
the assertion that blacks commit more
there's more police in your neighborhood
because blacks commit more crime is just
virulently racist openly racist
and then the clip continues because then
they just they're breaking their own
arms patting themselves on the back
about all of the contributions that
Western culture has provided and
denigrating third world countries as
having done nothing for the world it's
all again part and parcel pattern and
practice standard operating procedure
for virulent Sinister white supremacists
watch this so you have heads of art
museums saying the Western Tradition 5
000 years of art is racist because there
weren't black sculptures in 5th Century
BC Athens well there were no blacks in
Houston yeah but they're willing to tell
people they're willing to tell young
people coming to museums for the first
time see this collection through the
lens of racial exclusion which is poison
classical music heads are also saying oh
the reason that there were no black
composers in in 15th century Flanders is
racism no the demographically Europe was
white until the 20th century so that is
heartbreaking but yes up to a point
you're right that the
the the elite white perpetrators of
racial preferences when it comes to
their own immediate lives do expect that
Merit will will Triumph on the other
hand
for their own institutions corporations
are uh mandating that managers get
promoted based their own hiring of
blacks and promotion of blacks and our
setting just Preposterous uh hiring
standards that can't possibly be met
given the academic skills Gap I mean the
it you it doesn't matter what objective
10 seconds
sorry we sorry Heather we're up against
a break but we're gonna have to be back
and just close the point show me
anything from the third world that is as
beautiful as Beethoven's Fifth you can't
some things are more beautiful than
others Heather thank you so much
others show me something from the third
world that's more beautiful than
Beethoven's Fifth you can't
he proclaims arrogantly
this is White Privilege run amok this is
two people glad handing one another
while trafficking in white supremacy
and this is mainstream republicanism
like it's never been before obviously
racism has been a creeper in Republican
politics for decades
we witnessed it with the with the
southern strategy and how how it gained
a foothold when Reagan announced his
campaign a Californian announced his run
for presidency in the 80s in Mississippi
and now it's taken a foothold
it's gross
there's a name that you should become
more familiar with as we move on in this
Republican majority in the House of
Representatives and that is James Comer
Republican of Kentucky he is the chair
of the house oversight and
accountability committee
an important spot an important
uh committee assignment especially for a
chairman
he has colleagues who will join him
valiantly in their fight to provide
oversight
in the Congress Paul gosar a vowed white
nationalist Lauren bobert
High School Dropout multi-time fail
failure at the GRE or excuse me the GED
thinking of grad school stuff and
Marjorie Taylor green prolific
conspiracy theorist
Q Anon adherent they're also there with
him in James Comer the reason I'm saying
you're going to know his name more is
because he's going to be making the
rounds
the Press is going to be asking him
questions about what his agenda is what
do you plan to do
as chairman of the house oversight and
accountability committee
and uh you I hope will not be surprised
to know that he even categorizes himself
as just an average guy with average
ability at best he says watch this and
then we'll play some other Clips keeping
this particular clip in mind as we move
forward
and I'm just an average guy
with average ability at best that's Fed
Up
with the process in Washington DC I'm
fed up with the public corruption I'm
fed up with the excessive spending and I
want to do something about it and that's
that's my
goal now look this could be true he
could be an average guy with average
average abilities at best and some
people might be happy with that some
people may think oh we need more of a
Citizens representative uh segment of
our country it should be a citizen
government and I believe that to be true
but there's a certain skill set an
intellect level that you should
um just by virtue of qualification not
by some constitutional standard of
whether or not you're able to run for
office but you should be Adept at
certain things you shouldn't be just an
average guy with average ability at best
especially when you're the chairman of
the house oversight and accountability
committee wrangling the likes of Lauren
bobert and Marjorie Taylor green and
Paul gosar
part of their their their their their
efforts in that committee will be
investigating obviously by the name of
the committee government oversight
and he vows not to be uh investigating
Donald Trump but and the reason he gives
flies in the face of the reason that
he's actually going to be investigating
Joe Biden it all doesn't make any sense
I don't expect anybody to expect it to
make sense coming from James Comer
Republican of Kentucky watch this
with respect to Trump you know a lot of
the media I went on I love Pam Brown and
our our friends she's from Kentucky went
on CNN last night her last night on that
show uh she says well you know you why
aren't you investigating Trump's
mishandling of documents there's a
special counsel
there's a special counsel and I'm
confident that special counsel is
looking at everything and Trump has been
investigating for six years fighting
documents although it sounds like you
are planning on asking the national so
you are asking questions about Trump's
documents what was in them how they got
there I I would I'm going to try to
explain this as best I can we're
investigating the Biden family for
influence peddling
we learned that they have
classified documents in multiple
locations
we are concerned is that part of the
influence pedal I don't know
just an average guy with average ability
at best you can't even keep his nonsense
straight he's not you heard him not
investigating Donald Trump because
there's been assigned a special counsel
but he is investigating Biden
for the thing he's not investing
investigating Trump for even though
there's also been a special counsel
appointed in the Biden case
and then he's like oh let me pause here
and try to gather my thoughts uh let me
uh try to explain this as best I can now
that I got myself in this pickle I'm
just an average guy with average ability
and intellect at best
Emily I believe that was what her name
was questioning him there
and then when she presses him a little
bit further about other things that
maybe he should be investigating like
what took place in Memphis with Tyree
Nichols
he just said Well it has really crossed
my mind I haven't even thought about
that because Joe Biden it's a five alarm
fire
because Joe Biden is volunteered that
they found classified information he
wasn't hoarding it he didn't abscond
with it as soon as they found out they
they spilled the beans on themselves but
that needs investigated not rampant
systemic police abuse of American
citizens unarmed American citizens watch
this stupid stupid moment I encourage
Jim to work with me on on the stuff that
we're looking into and oversight I stay
out of his business in judiciary okay so
you don't think it's necessarily
something I should be looking into I
haven't even thought about it to be
honest with you I mean I I was asked
about it it's a terrible thing certainly
there are bad apples in in every
profession bad politicians bad police
officers and they need to be held
accountable so I'm confident those
police officers are going to be held
accountable he's confident they're going
to be held accountable but not by him
not by congress not by the chairman of a
very powerful committee with with
so much in its purview
there's bad apples everywhere
look I'm just an average guy with with
sub average abilities y'all why would I
look at that
bad apples what horrible luck for Tyree
Nichols that every single armed agent of
the state that responded to to to uh
address him under the authority and the
color of law what bad luck that every
single one of those cops happened to be
one of the bad apples
or is it more likely that the the
epidemic of Bad Apple dumb in policing
in America is far more advanced than
many people would like to believe
and this is a member of Congress who
could do something about it but instead
he's just an average guy
with an average skill set
speaking of average skill sets Molly
Hemingway
and Harris Faulkner at Fox News Harris
Faulkner not part of the uh the the
infotainment the entertainment side of
Fox News but one of their straight
reporters
foreign
recently Brian Cranston I know this is
going to seem out of the blue here but
this is what this is about Brian
Cranston recently appeared on Bill
Maher's podcast I can't remember the
name of it
um random things or dumb things or
bigoted things or I don't I don't
remember the name but in it they started
talking about CRT because Bill Maher is
now a useful idiot or maybe a willing
participant in moral Panic related to
critical race Theory and the the
conversation started in and and Brian
Cranston said he thinks that critical
race Theory should be taught to Children
it would be beneficial
where Bill Maher took him to task for
that or disagreed at the very least and
this conversation between Molly
Hemingway a right-wing provocateur and
if Harris Faulkner picks up there but I
wanted to give you the the background
and the context of this clip watch this
after crankson said it ought to be
taught in schools let's pause there and
just go right back to Molly if we could
to get your reaction
yeah well Bill Maher is and Brian
Cranston had this discussion on a
podcast where Cranston says that we have
not done enough to deal with our history
and not enough is being taught I think
Brian Cranston should learn his own
history such as about the Civil War
which was the bloodiest war that we went
through all of it has been done to deal
with the you know original sin as people
say of American slavery and we need more
history not the corrupted false sort of
propaganda history that is being pushed
by left-wing activists that teaches
hatred of the country will you and I say
this a lot we need more information in
General on everything and then let
people decide what you know from what
everything they learn how they live
their own lives
I I've always argued the beginning of
freedom is with as much information as a
journalist we both agree to this as you
can possibly have so you can make the
best decisions Molly Hemingway a
pleasure to have you in Focus today
thank you
this should be taught at a graduate
level in a in a a course on hypocrisy
one I hope that you noted the little
chuckle there as Molly Hemingway
referred to slavery as our original sin
you know our original sin chuckle
chuckle nudge nudge joke joke
it was indeed the original sin of this
country
the enslavement of millions of human
beings
for prophet's sake
to to make rich white men in this
country richer
not wider that's not possible but
certainly richer
and for them to laugh it off
is disgusting
but this entire thing about more we need
more history taught not but not the woke
history not CRT history we can't teach
about Jim Crow we can't teach about
redlining we can't teach about slavery
or convict Leasing
or or just the the
voter suppression
an oppression of blacks over the course
of the entirety of white man's existence
on this continent no no no that's CRT
that's dangerous
but they do they say oh more
Harris Faulkner argues for as much
information as possible which is in
direct contravention and contradiction
of of the point that they're trying to
say that not that history
not the history that causes people to
hate America listen
I love my country and because I love my
country I criticize my country I served
for years in the United States Marine
Corps because of some level of
patriotism some love of country
so critic being critical of one's
country it's like being critical of your
family your brother your mother your
father your cousin your uncle it's not
because you hate them
if you have a best friend that does
something that's a little shitty and you
criticize them you don't hate them
if you look back on past relationships
I'm dumbing this down for an audience
that doesn't need it but come on
Molly Hemingway Harris Faulkner
participants in the whitewashing of the
the stashing away in a Cupboard the
parts of American history that they
don't like that make them uncomfortable
they're not able to exist in in the
space that is that is uncomfortable for
them
and we need to as a society create that
space for our children when we teach
them
so they can have two conflicting points
and and deal with it yes you can love
your country
while also acknowledging the wrongs that
we've committed in the past the sins
against our fellow man
because if we don't and we're unable to
we're far more likely to create those
same mistakes and commit those same sins
get it together
Fox News
once again I am Jesse dollar Moore I
host the dollar more daily on YouTube I
host a podcast called I doubt it and uh
you can follow me on social media at
Dollar Moore on Instagram Twitter and
Tick Tock I'd love to see you there
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
welcome back to the program I am Jesse
dollar Moore sitting in for David
packman while he is away
I saw this clip on Twitter and I thought
I would share it with you it um it got
me into thinking and this might be the
only time in the history of all time
that something that Lauren bobert said
gave me pause it made me think
I mean they're asking her hair so are
you going to endorse Donald Trump for
president his run in 2024
and uh we're gonna play our answer but
it sparked in me
curiousness to get to the bottom of who
actually has come out and publicly
endorsed Donald Trump first we'll get to
the we'll get to the clip of Lauren
bobert and then we'll uh we'll get to
the list here we go
um are you officially endorsing for
president Trump for president 2024
I don't think I haven't endorsed
president Trump of course I support him
uh for for being our next president
um I I think it's going to be a
fantastic
race I can't wait until he actually
starts campaigning and of course I
endorse president Trump a lot of ums
there you would think that the media
Acumen of these individuals who are now
who've now been in Congress for for a
full term you think they'd get it
together but that is just not the case
so let's look at this particular list of
people who have endorsed ex-president
Donald Trump
um as I like to say when I turned 40
about 15 minutes after turning 40 my
eyes just started decided not to work so
here's a list I'm not going to go
through the whole thing it's quite long
if you're watching uh on video you can
you'll see it on screen here but this is
the there's it's broken up by federal
officials U.S senators U.S
representatives Governors State
executive officials state legislators
local and County officials International
politicians party officials and
individuals and then organizations
so here's Federal officials which I'll
just spoiler alert most of these people
are people who worked for Donald Trump
in the White House they're not federal
officials there is one though of node
and that's Jeffrey Lord who was the
White House associate political director
from 1987 to 1988. he used to work for
CNN uh he worked in the Reagan
Administration he's not really a he's a
political director he's not a federal
official but we got Michael Flynn
he is a notable endorser of Donald Trump
he uh famously pledged allegiance to Q
anon on 4th of July a few years ago
here's Sebastian Gorka famous endorser
of Donald Trump very important endorser
of Donald Trump here he is wearing his
FBI shirt uh fascist Bureau of
intimidation
very very important
cash Patel of course
insurrectionist Dan scavino a federal
official Donald Trump's former caddy and
then we go to Senators there's only two
of 100
members of the United States Senate you
got Lindsey Graham and you got Tommy
tuberville
uh U.S representatives it really is a
who's who of the Insurrection here Andy
Biggs Lauren bobert Madison cothorne
Matt Gates Paul gosar Marjorie Taylor
Greene Ronnie Jackson Jim Jordan Mary
Miller the appraiser of Hitler and the
list goes on and on uh there of the same
ilk Wendy Rogers there's also a theme
Here of election deniers
International politicians there's only
one on the list and
it is renowned alpha male Nick Adams
I mean listen uh what what hope would
Donald Trump have of becoming president
of the United States of America once
again if he didn't have the
full-throated support
of Nick Adams the clown account on
Twitter
we've got uh Jerry Falwell Jr Kimberly
Kimberly Guilfoyle the girlfriend of
Donald Trump Jr Charlie Kirk
Kerry Lake Mike Lindell Randy Quaid the
actor Roger Stone Donald Trump Jr Eric
Trump Lara Trump Melania Trump
no Ivanka Trump though
Jon Voight and Lynn wood the conspiracy
theorist
uh extraordinaire
this doesn't bode well for Donald Trump
that the campaign style of intimidation
that has worked in the past is starting
to diminish
he doesn't have the sway that he once
had he certainly still does and there is
a fear element that's why some people
are gonna are gonna wait till the last
minute and see where the wind blows
before they make a decision but uh it's
not looking good for Donnie boy relative
to endorsements and to be honest it's
going to be pretty exciting I say that
with a little tension in my my voice and
mind because Ron DeSantis as much as as
he is popular in Florida
is a quite the uncharismatic character
and on a national stage he's going to
Wither on the vine but we are we are
excited about 2024 to see what takes
place and to cover it
the whole way
in the news lately you've obviously been
hearing a lot about Tyree Nichols and
police brutality if you've watched the
tape the police recordings the the body
cam recordings that have been released
you know just how disgusting and
heart-wrenching the footage was
and there's been
the con in the in the conservative media
sphere one
is that it was terrible what took place
uh and then there's the other which is
this wouldn't have happened if he'd only
complied those cops did nothing wrong
and we're gonna play a little bit of
both here
Jesse Waters a parent expert on choke
holds
oddly enough uh had this to say on Fox
News
Banning chokeholds dealing with uh no
warrant searches uh dealing with
accreditation of police departments it's
necessary that we do all these things
but not sufficient typical Washington
politician the Memphis Police didn't use
a single Chokehold that entire time but
Democrats want to ban them a Chokehold
done properly with a subdued Tyree and
had him handcuffed
one there were many cops
on top of literally on top of the 140
pound Tyree Nichols
large men of giant physical stature
couldn't get him under control is that
what you're saying Jesse Waters
and you know or maybe you don't because
you're a dum-dum but you know as well as
the rest of us that Senator Durbin from
Illinois was not talking about
legislation based on this specific case
he's talking about chokeholds and their
misuse in cases all across the country
year after year after year after year
it's not disingenuous to say there's all
of these elements in all of these cases
that we need to look at from a
legislative standpoint and maybe that's
one of the things we need to occur if it
didn't work in this particular case or
it wouldn't have affected this
particular case isn't the point
but it doesn't matter to Fox News now
let's jump over to Newsmax where Grant
stitchfield is making the other case
which is if Tyree Nichols had just
complied and done what his killer said
to do he wouldn't have been killed
but here are some of the facts that
people aren't talking about
this all could have been avoided with
one simple move
Tyree Nichols could have complied from
the moment he was pulled out of that car
if you watch this interaction
he never really complies until the very
end
he doesn't comply until the very end
dumb dumb Grant stenchfield says
when was he to comply Grant was it when
they stood him up
and punched him in the face
is it when they had him pinned to the
ground and got running starts to kick
him in the head
is that when he should have complied
Grant stenchfield
it has been said I didn't originate it
but it's been said that cruelty is the
point for conservative politics in
conservative politics whether it be
owning the libs or whatever cruelty is
the point that's how you get the the the
the passions inflamed in Naga world and
that's exactly what this is it's not
just pathetic excuse making
for uh Jack booted armed agents of the
state who uh summarily executed an
unarmed citizen on the streets on the
Suburban streets of Memphis
it's all
listen if we do not get a handle on the
rhetoric if we do not get a handle on
the other side of the aisle and their
carelessness
and their uh lack of concern for
Humanity we're going to be a more
bifurcated Nation than we have ever been
when it is Sport for them to act as
cruel as possible
there's no conversation to be had
and I'd love to know what you think
about all of this we could mix it up in
the comments
David's got a voicemail line this should
be a conversation that continues uh in
the following weeks
I am Jesse dollar Moore I'd love to have
you subscribe to my YouTube channel if I
am your flavor of political commentator
you can go over and subscribe to the
dollar more daily I have a podcast
called I doubt it podcast or you can
um
follow me on social media
at Dollar Moore on Twitter and Instagram
and Tick Tock thanks a lot
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show welcome
back to the show I am Jesse dollar more
standing in sitting in actually as you
can see sitting in for David packman
while he is away listen over the course
of the of the the first few days of the
year when Congress was coming in and the
new majority of Republicans took over we
witnessed the absolute debacle that was
the election of of Kevin McCarthy as
Speaker of the House the 15 votes that
it took the day upon day upon day of
trying to find out who was going to be
Speaker of the House of Representatives
and Matt Gates led the effort Matt Gates
and Lauren bobert and Chip Roy there was
a few bad actors
although it is kind of a lesson in the
enemy of my enemy can also be my friend
even though they're certainly not
friends it was all chaotic and you know
kind of entertaining to watch a lot of
people will say that oh it was bad for
the institution and all of that and I
don't really take part in all of that
the the more disorganized they are the
better it is for the country because the
little damage they're able to do
but Matt Gates was one of these ring
leaders here in this and
um Ari melber I don't know why but Ari
melber had Matt Gates on his show to
talk about this and they spent a lot of
time and this is the reason listen I'm
not going to say be so critical that I
would say you shouldn't have him on your
show but what good does it do you're not
going to get to the truth if you ask him
questions Matt Gates is going to
systematically lie to you right to your
face over and over and over uh in
classic Matt Gates Republican fashion so
I don't understand it but he was there
and we need to talk about it he was
asked specifically about what secret
deal was made with McCarthy to actually
get him the votes to become speaker
there's obviously a mini page 40 page
document outlining the rules and going
forward some of the the procedures that
will govern this particular Congress but
there was also like a three or four page
document that's in secret that no one
knows the contents of of exactly what
was negotiated
and this is important for a number of
different reasons one mainly because of
the hypocrisy of the Republican party
and this particular flavor of Republican
that acts like transparency in
government is what we should be going
for when in actuality they're not
interested in that at all watch this
appearance by Matt Gates on MSNBC so you
mentioned Personnel that is something
that has been reportedly written down
and agreed to on the side a sort of a
side deal here's congresswoman mace on
some of that
you don't know what they got or didn't
get we haven't seen it we don't have any
idea what promises were made or what
gentlemen's handshakes were made
let's get into this maybe we resolved it
once and for all right here on live TV
uh you have a 55-page rules package that
part is public under the rules we could
put up reporting on that we all know
about that then you have reporting of a
secret three-page agreement reading here
from Punchbowl McCarthy and his allies
hash this out with the freedom caucus
it's got the other concessions including
rules committee that's Personnel I
believe what you just referred to and
other things
Point Blank Congressman have you or your
staff seen this additional agreement in
writing in any form
yeah it took multiple forms there was
specifically a side-by-side sheet where
we made offers to McCarthy there were
some offers he accepted some he modified
some he rejected just like you'd see in
any negotiation I could tell you that
Thomas Massey chip Roy Ralph Norman
being on the rules committee would not
have happened but for this negotiation
folks like representative Clyde
representative cloud two great
conservatives on the Appropriations
Committee that's a direct result of
these negotiations and this week we'll
be voting on Paul gosar's legislation to
end the covid National Emergency that
was a piece of power why the McCarthy
kind of I'll let you continue but the
question where I'm going is why keep
that secret
I'm what are your questions I'm happy to
tell you any element I'm actually quite
proud of the work product so it's no
secret at all the product though I I
appreciate you here taking questions but
why not release the written product that
exists and it's currently been kept
secret and for context uh you and others
have talked about bringing transparency
to governments one thing to hear it
described and another thing for the
government now the the house Republican
majority to just release whatever this
underlying material is here's a little
bit of how you and some others have
sounded about government secrecy
the American people are tired of the
swamp games we had the audacity to want
to know what in the world was going on
behind closed doors why not commit to
releasing the written agreement or
working to get it released tonight
yeah I have no objection to that that's
what I'm talking about there's no
answers there well we agreed to some
things some things were agreed to other
things were not agreed to well there you
go all transparent
I don't know that it there was any
efficacy that nothing was gained from
this other than yeah he's a liar and we
know he's a liar
what we do know though is that Kevin
McCarthy did make a deal
and as a result of that deal some of
those names that he mentioned and he
rattled off very quickly they're some of
the most radical in the Congress Thomas
Massey him and his family taking
pictures with their AR-15s uh Lauren
bober
on on very important committees on the
house uh oversight and accountability
committee Paul gosar is on that
committee Marjorie Taylor green is on
that committee not only is Marjorie
Taylor green on that committee she's on
Homeland Security
she's on the covet Origins committee
all of this should bring alarm bells
ringing in your head about what kind of
dirty dark room back room deals Kevin
McCarthy made with these Maniacs Andrew
Clyde
the man who said that the Insurrection
against the United States of America it
was just like a normal tourist visit
chip Roy Ted Cruz's former Chief of
Staff
this is where we are in our Congress
this is our Kong they act like they want
to get so much things done yet they're
all they're going to be doing is focus
on investigations they're not going to
work with the Biden Administration to
pass anything useful or reasonable for
the American people because that's not
on the agenda owning the libs is on the
agenda cruelty is on the agenda
because they know look they'll they're
going to pass bills and brag about the
bills they passed that are going to be
radical in nature that have no chance of
even getting through the Senate
not to mention getting to the
president's desk for a signature we need
to play for them the I'm Just a Bill
yeah I'm only a bill that The
Schoolhouse Rock
to re-educate them on how a bill is made
that their role as legislators
is to write and pass legislation for the
express purpose of getting to the
president's desk for signature
instead this is what we get
very disheartening
the other thing that I want to talk
about is actually some good news and
that is Donald Trump's accountability
the March for consequence for Donald
Trump continues there is news that the
former publisher of the National
Enquirer I believe his name is David
pecker is now speaking to the grand jury
in Manhattan that has been impaneled
surrounding the hush money payments made
to Stormy Daniels I'm going to read a
little bit from this New York Times
article entitled Manhattan prosecutors
begin presenting Trump case to Grand
Jury The Manhattan District Attorney's
decision represents a dramatic
escalation of the inquiry and
potentially sets the case on a path
forward toward criminal charges against
the former president
this is what we need we need fewer
business uh cases that result in 1.61
million dollar fines for an extensive I
mean he claims to be a billionaire even
if he's not he's worth hundreds of
millions of dollars a single one and a
half million dollar fine isn't going to
be much of a bump in the road for Donald
Trump it's certainly not going to
dissuade him or deter him from his uh
criminal activity but this might when
there's actual criminality and jail time
on the line the Manhattan District
Attorney's office on Monday began
presenting evidence to a grand jury
about Donald J Trump's role in paying
hush money to a porn star during his
2016 presidential campaign laying the
groundwork for potential criminal
charges against the former president in
the coming months according to people
with knowledge of the matter the grand
jury was recently impaneled and the
beginning of witness testimony
represents a clear signal that the the
district attorney Alvin L Bragg is
nearing a decision about whether to
charge Mr Trump on Monday one of the
witnesses was seen with his lawyer
entering the building in lower Manhattan
where the grand jury is sitting the
witness David pecker is the former
publisher of the National Enquirer the
Tabloid that helped broker the deal with
the porn star Stormy Daniels now if you
remember this case
you will know that the well there's a
there's a term called I believe it's
catch and kill where a journalist Outlet
like this will offer money to buy the
rights to the story and then do nothing
with it but they the the person they
work with Stormy Daniels in this case
would sign an NDA not allowing them to
ever tell the story again because the
rights to that story were owned by the
by the newspaper I'm using that very
Loosely here with the National Enquirer
and that seems to be something along the
lines of what was dealt with here with
Donald Trump and Michael Cohen who by
the way pled guilty pleaded guilty to
these charges there was criminality here
that has been proven there have been
convictions related to this but just not
Donald Trump
as prosecutors prepare to reconstruct
the events surrounding the payment for
Grand jurors they have sought to
interview several witnesses including
the tabloids former editor Dylan Howard
and two employees at Mr Trump's company
the people said Mr Howard and the Trump
organization employees Jeffrey
McConaughey and Deborah taseroff have
not yet testified before the grand jury
the prosecutors have also begun
contacting officials from Mr Trump's
2016 campaign one of the people said and
in a sign that they want to corroborate
these witness accounts the prosecutors
recently subpoenaed phone records and
other documents that might shed light on
the episode a conviction is not a sure
thing in part because a case could hinge
on showing that Mr Trump and his company
falsified records to hide the payout
from voters days before the 2016
election a low-level felony charge that
would be based on largely untested legal
Theory the case would also rely on the
testimony of Michael D Cohen Mr Trump's
former fixer who made the payment and
who he himself pleaded guilty to federal
charges related to the hush money in
2018. so listen I I don't understand the
trepidation from The New York Times
reporting here because we have a guilty
we have a conviction in the case related
you think Michael Cohen was making hush
money payments for Donald Trump out of
the goodness of his own heart out of his
own pockets
come on
this is something to follow Donald Trump
is in dire need of legal
consequence for his actions in dire need
of consequence for his crimes whether it
be this whether it be obstruction of
justice whether it be inciting an
Insurrection against the United States
of America but it has to start somewhere
and I'm glad that Alvin Bragg is back on
the case after kind of shying away from
the initial charges I'm glad that this
is before a grand jury that is where it
starts and hopefully that's where we're
going to get some traction
once again my name is Jesse dollimore
you can subscribe to me on YouTube just
search Jesse dollar more or dollar more
daily you can also follow me on on
Instagram on Twitter on Tick Tock all
across the social media just search at
dollar more and of course you can
subscribe to my podcast my twice weekly
podcast co-hosted by the lovely and
talented Brittany page it's called I
doubt it
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
welcome back to the David Pacman show I
am Jesse dollamore sitting in for David
while he is away
[Laughter]
look some stories just bring me wow a
chef's kiss amount of joy is is chef's
kiss a measurement that I can use is how
much joy I feel when I get to talk about
Donald Trump Jr and his podcast
from Junior just started a podcast I
guess titled after his book of the same
name triggered and in it it is similar
to the videos you may or may not see on
Twitter where he gesticulates wildly and
look not being one who who lives in a
glass house and wants to throw stones
you know I'm somebody who gesticulates
I'm somebody who waves his hands around
maybe more than I should I certainly get
taken to task on it about it on YouTube
but Donald Trump Jr just has a
fundamental dis misunderstanding about
how air quotes work in some of these
videos he just sits there and and does
air quotes for several seconds in a row
at everything he says a shared desire to
keep quiet early on Biden's attorneys
and justice department investigators
both thought they had a shared
understanding about keeping the matter
quiet but they had very different
reasons
I mean seriously it could be leveraging
the fact that they have those secrets
and that Joe was irresponsible with them
to gain whatever advantage over the
United States of course of course they
had a desire to keep it quiet but the
fact that the media is quiet about it
the fact that if all the leftists don't
say anything about it that in and of
itself is actually the story uh it's
just bizarre and this is like maybe the
third episode of his podcast and this
mashup I believe is from
um Ron filipowski on Twitter and it
really it says a lot about what
conservatives tune into and where they
get their information and what they find
credible this is a remarkable clip this
mashup that is as all over the place as
really anything that I've witnessed in
recent memory it is it is schizophrenic
in nature to use it to colloquialize
that term watch this nuttiness
from the ex-president's son Donald Trump
Jr
discredited
truly but the media always a discredit
and they I don't think
I don't think constantly said they're
discredited that's the way the media
does their things because journalists
actually refuse to actually be
journalists like God forbid they do a
job God forbid they don't just rubber
stamp the Democrat talking points it's
that while the company wouldn't dare
admit it publicly they do mutate viruses
branded conspiracy theorists well like
every conspiracy theorist if you wait a
couple weeks you'll be proven right who
would possibly do that what is this like
the 1980s like are we still pretending
that all of these people have our best
intentions are the highly educated and
sophisticated media class that know
better do that when elections when
everything's won by basis points margins
a couple points here and there you know
those people who aren't paying attention
that much you know what if I can get
that guy even wondering maybe he doesn't
even show up big part of I think while
we're in Ukraine I've read some really
interesting threads about like sort of
the the labs that are over there I'm not
going to talk about them I got to
research it a little bit more but like
look at why else we may be in Ukraine
and why maybe it's okay if we let other
people kind of mutate viruses and when
the Russians do it it's bioengineering
and when we do it it's checking to make
sure we're preventing Panda yeah
he's feeling really unsafe right now
really he was sort of like well you know
we do this but not really that much I
mean what's a couple of mutations right
I mean folks it takes one
[Laughter]
uh doing his own research Donald Trump
Jr there
talking about how every conspiracy
theory if you wait a couple weeks it
ends up being true
listen this is hilarious and this is
funny and it's mockable because he's a
but it is troubling because of the
fact that there's a wide swath of the
country who looks at this individual
this troubled goon
and thinks he's credible and thinks he's
smart and thinks he has it together and
thinks he has access to information that
they don't because he's the son of the
ex-guy
we're in trouble
I'd love to know what you think about
this I know David has a phone number you
can mix it up in the comments on YouTube
this is something that I would love to
get your take on once again I am Jesse
dollamore I host I doubt it podcast on
everywhere that podcasts are I host the
dollar more daily on YouTube and you can
catch me on social media on Twitter
Instagram and Tick Tock I am at Donovan